so welcome to the chest for Knights
class I'm for those who don't know Grand
Master Eric Hanson this is the start of
me being here for three weeks so you'll
see me around if you come by any day of
the week and today I wanted to look at
something I actually dread it a lot when
I was a kid and games not like
theoretical and games but end games
nonetheless recently there was a
tournament going on in Russia a very
high-level tournament and I was just
looking at the games and today we're
gonna look at a game between a couple
Chinese grandmasters strong ones and
what happened is what happens in
Grandmaster games sometimes as the guys
resign in positions where most people
wouldn't resign and especially when I
was younger I'd like look at a game and
be like why did they resign here why
didn't they play on and what that is
gonna require us to do is analyze what
they saw which why they didn't provoke
the resignation so we have a position
here I'm not gonna get to the port we're
gonna get to where one player resigned
it's only a couple moves from here we're
gonna get to this position it's black
just played rook g8 to g2 so this is
about 20 moves into the game they've
reached a rock end game if we take a
minute to just analyze this you know
materials even whites King is in the
center it can be a good or bad depending
but pawn structure wise White has to
pawn islands and black has really pawn
for pawn formations three pawn islands
h7f seven d6 so when I look at the pawn
structure I think that's a factor I
think about in the endgame that favors
white when I look at the rook activity
there's none how many pieces look of the
rooks well White's rook is attacking b6
blacks rook is attacking b2 all the rock
has pressure on c4 and White's rook
controls the e-file so it looks it looks
a little balanced in terms of the rook
activity at least that first glance
otherwise whites King is probably better
than blacks King go you want your king
normally in the center that's something
to always consider as long as you're not
getting checkmate or something it's so
much nice to use your king to defend
upon than rook you want your book to be
active so I would say you know I like
White's position I don't know about you
guys I prefer White's position
that's my just initial and I just look
at it I prefer White's position totally
feel free to if you guys have a question
or disagree or think black is better we
can discuss it
what but one thing you know if white has
a better pawn structure like and that's
how I judged it the pawn islands after
rook G to White's move here which I
think black actually missed surprisingly
a few moves ago it's very normal but
very strong so you have an option here
the rook takes d6 is White's one obvious
move what's black gonna do after rook
takes d6 yeah yeah yeah
rook takes b2 so we're trading one for
one and that might be good that might be
bad when we take the d6 pawn that is a
passed pawn we're gonna have afterwards
at the same time black when they take on
b2 route 66 rook takes p2 White's pawn
structure is not as nice anymore though
now it's now it's kind of technically
three-point islands 2 3 you know so and
a2 is being attacked so is it is that an
even trade I guess the question might be
can white protect this pawn structure
does you have to trade you have to trade
one for one you have to trade one for
one here or can you like keep your pawn
structure nice because otherwise White
has an advantage with it with the pawn
structure it's important to not have
pawn islands because then they're not as
loose they support each other and you
don't need to defend them as much also
most of you guys know probably two ponds
connected pawns you know they can push
each other they can go down the board
and protect each other
we're split pawns it's kind of like a
bowling you know they're just they're
just very weak they're you know just
they can just be picked off they can't
support each other they require a rock
or a king to defend them so white played
b3 here and sure we're trading black can
take on a - black can do rook takes a -
here and again we're we are trading a
pawn for a pawn but it's not the same
type of fun first of all pawns close to
the center are usually considered
advantageous maybe they you know on the
side there they don't control as many
squares and in the in this case in the
center
it keeps the pawn structure you know we
want to keep the pawn chain active so
pawns in the center are normally good
because whoever controls the center you
know usually has has more space you can
go to either side pretty easily so the
black did not trade but we see just move
like b3 which to me it wasn't even
obvious you know would necessarily be
obvious is a big is a big very very
important move now after a rook takes a
to work takes d6 we did trade one for
one but white white White's pawn
structure is still intact and so really
like you know the main the main thing
we're really analyzing is the pawn
structure there's rooks and that's a
very important part of the endgame but
White's advantage is entirely with with
the pawn structure and if we want our DD
5 fun now it's a past fun to be strong
and we want the pawns behind it to be to
be good and at least with b3 our King is
close to it and it's yeah it's it looks
it looks looks very hard for black to
stop stop this pawn pawn chain so what
actually happens so white played b3
black played rook to e8 they're like
that's not a good trade because that's a
passed pawn for an 82 pawn protected
passed pawn and protected passed pawn is
better than a passed pawn protected by
the way means upon a pawn is protecting
it I have two rookie six black resigned
so that to me that was like YY resign
here you know that's that's still very
early even for maybe a grandmaster
standards
so black resigned after rook III to e6
didn't play a single more move I I don't
suggest you guys should resign earlier
things like that but then when I look at
a game like this and it's not you know
not a game of mind I ask myself why did
why did black resign I don't just like
accept it I'm like just because they
resigned doesn't mean I think it's right
I have to see it for myself
so that's that's what I do when I study
some games and so here I want to ask you
guys why why did black resign and you're
not going to know entirely why but what
are some positions that look quite
uncomfortable for black or look quite
okay so what that means is we have to go
a bit deeper in this position because
they didn't go any deeper
so after rookie six black resigned a
sample way for you to start would be
well black probably definitely didn't
like something after rook takes a to
rook takes d6 let me ask you how is the
rook endgame with just one work on the
board how what do you guys think about
this this endgame right here because
this is directly possible would it still
be four pawns to four pawns and you know
there's a very common thing and just
like all working games are drawn it's
not the case but a lot of working games
can be drawn if you're good at defending
working in teams you can defend down
upon sometimes down to pawns and you can
draw if you get really good at it so
there is some truth that you know that's
a lot of them are drawn but what do you
guys think about this position was black
right to be maybe afraid of this we just
you know there's no necessarily right
answer we're just analyzing you know
there so there's no no there's no right
right answer here necessarily they
didn't play it out but what are what are
some things we you know look for both
sides sure so blacks King is pretty bad
like whites King is much better gonna
gain some more space mm-hmm yeah so so
White's King position is a very
important fact King position you know I
see this all the time when you don't
know what to do in the endgame and
you're looking for a move if you can
improve your King do it you know get
your king the King is totally safe on d3
King position the king is a very
valuable piece so White's King is better
that contributes to his advantage
the pawn structure in my opinion is
better that that contributes to the
advantage but I still need to see more I
need to either see some variations or
something why black can't trade off
pawns or get their own pawns rolling any
comments guys yes yep did you have your
hand up yeah oh yeah that's fine no
sorry go ahead yes that that is a that's
a very important factor which you know
not all the pawns are equal whoever's
pawn whoever you know whoever Queens
first usually wins these end games
whoever has the potential Queen first so
which side is easier is easier for white
to Queen it's everybody agree there
what's the plan though to try to Queen
that deep on like it looks easier but we
still have thought we start to see some
actual moves you know they would have
played the game out and I think white
would have won but that's still not we
don't know we won't play the same moves
as that
I'm curious what you guys would do so
yes the D pawn can push it's further
advanced it's protected by its own pawns
so yes it looks more attractive but well
why is it still so good or so easy we
let's we need some moves for example
here let's say let's say it's black to
move let's say I play like rook H say
rook H - yes
why be six and not d7 why did you choose
BC there's two ways to attack it you
want to block it and I'm curious why you
did that
some people might be inclined to play
rook d7 to get the seventh rank and
attack the pawns why rook b6 that's very
good that's very good there's a couple
of good points there getting the rook
out of the way are we gonna push the D
pawn with our rook on d6 or anywhere on
the D file
no we need our pawn to get on the D file
so we do want to shift our look away
from that secondly rook to b6 for sure
we're gonna win the b7 pawn and you know
it's easy to slip up when you have two
good options rook d7 looks good but you
know there's still work d7 maybe they
can play b6 maybe be five but rook b6
there there are no are no possibilities
there in defending the b7 pawn and then
and then would have to to pass pawns and
also the pawn would be free to free to
push so rook b6 would be a very very
good move and yeah four to two reasons
we're winning the pawn on B son for sure
and we're clearing up space for the rook
location so let's say rook b6 rook takes
age five or six b7 what do you think of
this position so we went we're just
going a bit further we're just saying
what could have happened but in doing so
hopefully we look we learn a bit about
you know these design games yes
and any comments in the middle yeah you
sure so you know let's let's look at the
race now it's three pawns to three pawns
but now both sides have passed pawns I
mean black has a couple passed pawns
here White has the ones in the center
who you what do you guys prefer here
yeah
do you think white will win because in
the end game you know thing yeah because
in the end game at a certain point we
you know we almost have to try to figure
out who's gonna win it's gonna be a race
we have to almost calculate it out if
can you can it it's like it's like a
position like this white might be better
but better is a weird term when there's
so few pieces on board we're either
maybe winning or drawn or not let's go a
bit further and do a pawn race let's say
we're playing black let's say I played
rook g5 let's see who arrives first give
me some moves for both sides
give me some variations I want to hear
good good throw variations so I want to
I want to practice some calculation here
yes d6 move for black let's say let's
say King ee8 King it is that that good
King e8 yeah
d7 King d8
yes
King before I'm gonna play his black age
5 try to look ahead guys my moves were
very predictable yes in the green yeah
yeah
what's this can you call it the square
or as hard as C 5 C 5 okay yeah C 6 H 3
no see seven check double check and see
seven I'm going to take your pawn on g7
what's the better move than c7 yeah rook
b8 and we're Queenie and we're way ahead
I mean the pond isn't even on h2 so I
mean looking back I was trying to find I
was still like this is still very early
to resign but I'm starting to see some
reasons why black resigned but then when
I look at something like this could
black have improved so is there is there
anything else
I said rook h2 here is this just a
winning endgame for a white is this just
really good for white and if it is
winning then I mean that's that's I
thought I thought I thought the position
was just a little bit better for white I
mean if it's winning already that's
that's pretty serious without being up
any material without black playing
really bad news is this is there
something black can do better push their
pawns on f5 or something we're looking
for both sides here this is just you
know it's not my game or something but I
was just like trying to understand I
didn't think it was that bad I thought
you know you have a couple weaknesses
that's something but to just have no
hope yeah
yeah b7 well b7 to b5 what are we gonna
do is white are we gonna take or we
gonna play c5 do you want to split your
pawns or do you want to get two
connected pawns
what's better connect upon so what will
white do c5
so as I said if you guys can if you guys
suggest the move and you guys can
already think what the next move will be
for the other side
give me more than one move let's let's
practice that because an endgame
there aren't many as many possibilities
we we can start predicting and I mean I
mean the people who are good at end
games are also calculating you know
further and you know being being able to
see farther so so the endgame is
definitely not the part of the game
where we're playing one move at a time
so anything for black to do here or you
know is it's just a good resignation
yeah cuz I you guys wouldn't resign here
so and you should rook to a 1 and then
what's white gonna do same as before
or what so wreck a 1 we're gonna play
yeah rook b6 again there's black
hopeless against this and okay now the
pawn is hang but is there anything black
can do is or just just because maybe if
you guys see how easy it is that some of
these end games or winning you might
practice it a bit more I I didn't like
studying on game because I was like I
never got into end games or games are
boring but if it if I can just win
without even having to win upon then
that might change my mind
yes is there is there anything else back
I've done were you know it's good to try
to look for both sides that's how that's
how you you learn to be objective and
you learn to start predicting what your
opponent will play that will save you
time that'll improve your calculation so
anything else black could have done here
yeah
let's say kick okay let's say kickball
in which position actually it's black to
move here otherwise it's black to move
here yeah
King g7 what are we doing is white
actually there's something even better
probably probably we can play h6 check
we can also play h6 check and kick your
King right back but if we goes to the g8
its mate so he has to go here but rook
b6 1883 would be nice just the rook on
d6 also defends it that's because I know
you guys wouldn't resign in the initial
position but is there any hope then you
know what if we're I'm I just you know I
just want some space yeah the value of
connected passed pawns I mean I should
feel like it's it Trump's almost
everything here specifically so when you
have connected passed pawns
you want to keep that when you have a
pawn chain you wanna keep that beat b3
is a very important move there but I was
looking at this and it was just so
surprising originally but then I looked
and I just I don't see a single move for
white for black here but I'm waiting for
you guys to agree with me you guys don't
have to do agree with me it's just I
just look at these games until I'm like
yeah you know now I like until I
understand it's only until you
understand don't take my word for it but
we can play this worked in game out
that's how we improve our rook end games
play them out and make conclusions so I
I want you guys to fight for black
because you guys wouldn't resign here
you guys you guys will have bad rockin
games yeah we only have one guy trying
yes
I mean black guys black does not have to
trade rooks that's something here by the
way right here we don't have to trade
rooks we could play rook b8 we could
play rook e8 we don't have to trade
rooks and maybe we can try to get our
work to e7 rook c8 yeah let's go back
see it's it's not like you know we might
be missing something done that simple so
let's say right yeah rook c8
now if b5 we have time to play b5 white
can play c5
rook c8 are you still gonna are we still
gonna play rook p6 here what's what's
what's going on after rook c8 keep the
rooks connected okay so Brooke b6 would
you play rugby six and now what's black
gonna do we know what blacks gonna do
here I hope rook c7 we can play rugby it
but the rook is very passive on be it if
you can defend it like this we also
cover a few more squares you guys agree
which is better rook c7 rook b8 to
defend the pawn it does yes
c7 by a long shot okay c7 by long so
that's that's important because you know
no I've made that mistake before so what
about this position is this so good for
white I mean what's going on here I know
you doing guys don't like end games
that's why I'm bringing it up I don't
like in games either so is it better for
black to keep two rooks on the board or
one rook probably better to keep two
rooks that's probably something we can
we can say here then we can defend b7
yep yep and then but as I said after d6
we know a blacks gonna play right we're
practice
after d6 what's black in a play there's
only one move that defends b7 and
doesn't lose the rook after d6 Black has
to play rook d7 right is there anything
else tell me now you can't go to e7 you
can take the pawns on d6 now d6 would be
rook d7 but is that what you want to
play so I'm just is it is this is this
is this is this a better version well
this is fighting for black at least this
is a improvement to me but
once we finish this out for white once
we figure out why white also why black
resigned this position or didn't want to
go into this once we get through this
guy's will get to play some games but
what did black not like about this
position as well or just just something
that that yeah because we're not even
finding fighting chances any other
variation so in this variation h5 to h6
that's a good move
restricts the king what now what do we
do is black I don't know what would you
do is black
age - okay I just want you guys to play
it out there's not necessarily a right
answer here we're just I just want to
see why you know somebody resigned in
just a equal material work endgame p3 to
be four check and and then I'm gonna
check you again I mean this this was you
know black could have played on and
probably play this I think I think this
end game is very good for white but
there's still a little bit of fighting
but definitely you should keep both
rooks on the board for black and whites
just gonna try to create a connected
pass pawn so here you suggest at age six
let's say something like even age six
now and now I want to play c5 and c6 and
then rook b8 checkmate so again what
matters is whose pawns are gonna Queen
first so for example let's say we have
some position like this I play rook here
I want to trade off a pair of Brooks or
let's just say we say something like
that c5 rook g6 so we trade everything
off which pawn do we take with for
example
I've found her h-bomb let's say who's
better in this type of like if we trade
off a pair of rooks is this also just
way better for white because in it did
you play that King e4 yeah what matters
is who's really going to Queen first and
we're gonna bring our King in and play
c6 and it's much quicker than then black
black king of seven King here g5 and Wow
yeah probably just c6g for
Brooksie seven right can you get wha-hoo
and on just finger King and just bring
the King in
no it worked xd7 no Roxy sex just bring
the King in and yeah
why does wave way faster we can't take
the rook we'd have to move our rook back
but yeah the d6 pawn the d6 pawn is much
much that protected past pawn is much
more valuable than any of blacks pawns
so I mean in the end after I looked at
it I I I think I think black at least
was not wrong about resigning sometimes
I've resigned the game and then I
realized I shouldn't have given up but
in this case I don't see anything to
really stop stop stop white at all you
know my place c5 c6 here so yeah I know
I just I just hope you guys also agree
like I I think it's a game you resigned
way before any of us would resign but if
we if we actually look look a bit deeper
into the position we consider that the
rook activity the pawn structure this is
a really really superior pawn structure
so hopefully that will help you guys
avoid maybe getting pawn structures like
this is black when you make weaknesses
when you make weaknesses you can make
weaknesses but there are gonna be
consequences especially if you if you if
you last until the end game so it's
something to consider from both sides
you see that oh you know sometimes you
have a bad position you want to trade
down you want you just want to get rid
of let's say you're being attacked you
want to get rid of your opponent's
pieces but you have to you have to
consider how your position will be in
the endgame so analyzing end games is
important because it influences how
you're gonna decide you're your middle
game middle game position and in this
case if I if you shop if I show you guys
earlier on in the game black played very
recklessly and that's why their king is
on f8 and their pawns are like that and
and you know there was no chance no
chance to survive in the endgame after
playing so recklessly so yeah just just
some just some things Daniel I was just
just getting some analysis in since
I know most you guys don't win games
much I didn't do it I always hated doing
it so just looking at some rockin games
and palm structure from from a recent
game